[Music]
think of that powerful memory
make it
the happiest you can remember
it feels like no time has passed
and loads of times past
well i think this is the perfect time to
sit down with everyone and reminisce
[Music]
the thing that scared me the most
was the implication that the most
meaningful thing in our life was done
and there's something so joyous about
seeing everyone
and be like
there wasn't though
one of the highlights of my part was
when i had to pretend to be hermione
pretending to be better tricks i don't
like to be kept waiting i've still got
their teeth actually i'll put them in if
you want
my sister has children who have been
around 10 11 12 and i said math i don't
know about this voldemort what you're
being asked to play voldemort
[Applause]
you've got to do it
i wouldn't be the person i am without so
many people here
it's a very overwhelming thing because
i've watched you grow up and i've seen
kind of every stage of your life
when things get really dark and times
are really hard there's something about
harry potter that makes life richer it's
a strong bond that we'll always have
we're family and we will always be part
of each other's life
[Music]
you